[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت الحادي عشر بتوقيت
الرياضه انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
[موسيقى]
في اوكرانيا روسيا تصده هجومين وكييف
تستعيد ثلاث بلدات
بعد اوامر من شيجو بريجوجن قائد فاجنر
يتحدى من جديد ويرفض توقيع عقود مها وزاره
الدفاع
تفاهمات واشنطن وطهران بشل الاتفاق النووي
تدفع اسرائيل للاستعداد عبر استحداث فرع
جديد للتعامل مع ايران
في قصه انشغلت العالم والد احد الاطفال
الناجين في غابات الامازون يروي تفاصيل
الاتصال الاول
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه وبدايتها من
تطورات الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد فيبدو ان
اكياس قد حصدت اولى ثماره اذ اعلن الجيش
الاوكراني استعادته قريتي
جنوب شرق البلاد وقبل قليل اعلنت كييف
استعادتها قريه ثالثه واظهر الجيش مشاهد
لجنود يحملون العلم الاوكراني في بلده
بلاجودانتني التابعه لمقاطعه
يسعدني اعلان تحرير قريه بلاغودات بمنطقه
وكانت عمليه ناجحه ونحن الان نشهد النتائج
الاولى للهجوم المضاد
[موسيقى]
اما وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فاعلنت التصدي
لهجوم الاوكراني بسته زوارق مسيره على
سفينه تابعه لاسطول البحر الاسود بالقرب
من خطي انابيب يقعان على بعد 300 كم من
القرن وذكرت الوزاره ان قوتها تمكنت من
تدمير الزوارق السته اشارت الى ان طائره
مسيره تابعه لسلاح الجو الامريكي قامت
بعمليه استطلاع اثناء الهجوم
اكد رئيس مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه يا جوجل ان
قوته لن توقع اي عقد لوزير الدفاع
ان قرار وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الذي اعلنته
امس بضروره قيام المتطوعين بتوقيع عقود لا
ينطبق على مقاتليه مشددا على ان فاجنر لن
توقع اي عقود مع شيغو
معنا من موسكو يفديني
المحلل السياسي سيد افقيني اهلا بك معنا
اوكرانيا تعلن استعادتها ثلاث بلدات من
السيطره الروسيه هل بدا بدا الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني يؤتي ثماره
سيدي هل تسمعني الان سيد سيدوف سيد سيد
تسمعني الان بشكل واضح
نعم
سالتك عن سيطره اوكرانيا الان على ثلاث
بلدات من القبضه الروسيه هل هذه اولى
نتائج الهجوم المضاده الاوكراني
ليس هناك من تاكيدات من مصادر بكره غير
اوكرانيه وحتى المصادر الغربيه
تؤكد على انه لم يتم اثبات يعني هذا
الواقع واقع استرجاع الاستلام والسيطره
على ثلاثه بلدات
كما تقول المصادر الاوكرانيه وبالتالي
لابد من الحصول على ربما معلومات موضوعيه
استنادا الى عدد من المصادر وليس فقط تلك
التي تاتي من الجانب الاوكراني هزم ما
تشير اليه المصادر الغربيه سواء للامنيه
او الاستخباراتيه غير متاكده من صحه هذه
التقارير سيدي افقيني اذا كنا لا نستطيع
التثبت من صحه كما تصفها بالادعاءات
الغربيه والاوكرانيه يعني التصريحات
الروسيه هي تصريحات
هي تصريحات روسيه حجم الخلاف يبدو كبيرا
بينه وبين وزير الدفاع كيف يمكن فهم هذا
الخلاف بين هذه او هاتين القوتين
الروسيتين على الارض المعركه
اعتقد بانه سبب هذا الخلافه بسيط للغايه
وهو بالفعل مجموعه التي لعبت دورا كبيرا
في السيطره على بطموت كانت تعاني كما قال
السيد مرارا تعاني من نقص الذكر ولما تحصل
على ما يكفي منها وبالتالي هي بطبيعه
الحال تعبر عن عدم رضاها مع تصرف وزاره
الدفاع وهي واجهه انتقادات حاده اليه الان
يبدو ان الصوره تغيرت نوعا ما لان اولا
عناصر او على الاقل الجوز منه من سحبوا من
مدينه بطوط والان تسلم الامور فيها واحداث
الجيش الروسي اعتقد بان هذا الخلافه تم
احتوائه والتصريحات التي يبلي به حين
والاخر وسيف يعني الواضح من الانتقادات
المستمره
للجيش الروسي بانه وكانه يبحث عن دور اهم
في المعركه
في اوكرانيا هل برايك بوتين يمكن ان يذهب
بهذا الاتجاه اذا استمر تقهقر القوات
الروسيه قوات الدفاع الروسيه بالتالي
سيسلم الرايه لفاجنر افضل
بطبيعه الحال الرئيس الروسي الذي يقدم على
هذه الخطوه رغم انه طبعا قدر عاليا دور
مجموعه
ولكن واضح تماما ان الجزء الرئيسي والعلم
الاساسي للمعارك القادمه سوف يتحملها
الجيش الروسي النظامي وليس مجموعه شكرا
جزيلا
من موسكو
[موسيقى]
الى الان السودان لم تكد هدنه اليوم
الواحد تسجل ستارها حتى عادت الاشتباكات
العنيفه الى الاندلاع من جديد في السودان
ورغم قصر مدتها الى ان الهدنه الاخيره
احترمت اكثر من سابقاتها حيث التزم بها
الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع لكن
الطرفين لم ينتظران سوى عشر دقائق على
نهايه الهدنه ليعودا الى الاقتتال من جديد
وسمع قصف عنيف بالمدفعيه الثقيله في
الخرطوم وضاحيه ام درمان بشمال العاصمه
وايضا بمناطق جنوب الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
وسمع قصف عنيف بالمدفعيه الثقيله في
الخرطوم اذا وضحيه ام درمان شمال العاصمه
كما ذكرت وايضا بمناطق جنوب الخرطوم
وبعيدا عن التطورات الميدانيه قالت اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر ان فرق الحمايه
التابعه للجنه تستقبل اتصالات دائمه
للابلاغ عن حالات فقدان واختفاء وذلك منذ
بدء الصراع واوضحت اللجنه ان عمليات البحث
عن المفقودين تواجه الكثير من العقبات من
ابرزها استمرار الاقتتال الذي يعيق عمليات
التقصي
نستطيع الوضع في الخرطوم مع عمار ابو شيبه
ومن ام درمان مع مقداد حسن مرحبا بكما
معنا ابدا معك عمار في الخرطوم نستطلع معك
اذا الوضع بعد انتهاء هدنه اليوم الواحد
هل ما تزال المعارك والاشتباكات مستمره
اهلا بك يا صهيب واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام
وجميع الزملاء نعم في عده مناطق من
العاصمه الخرطوم دارت هذه الاشتباكات
وكانت عنيفه في عددنا المناطق واستمرت
لساعات في عدد المناطق الاخرى خاصه في
مناطق الشرق النيل حيث دارت اعنف
الاشتباكات منذ الصباح الباكر هذه
الاشتباكات انتقلت الى مدينه بحري ومن ثم
الى وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وجنوب وغرب
العاصمه الخرطوم وايضا في مدينه ام درمان
صوت اطلاق رصاص من خلفك
نعم بعد ان انتهت هذه الاشتباكات صهيب
تبقت هذه الاصوات من الاصوات المدافع الى
اصوات الاعير الناريه في عدد من المناطق
خاصه الشرقي وجنوبي العاصمه الخرطوم نستمع
بين فتره واخرى لاصوات الاعيره الناريه
يبدو انها طلقات تحذيريه في عدد من النقاط
البعيده او انها عمليات مناوشات ما بين
عدد من القوات في هذه المناطق خاصه وان مع
الدخول وحلول الظلام بنسبه كبيره تبدو
عمليات الاشتباك او المناوشات تقوم بشكل
متباعد وفي عده مناطق ما لم تكن هنالك
اشتباكات في مناطق مجاوره ما بين القوتين
على الارض الوضع الميداني الان عاد الى
حاله السكون ولكن تعكر صفه هذه الرصاصات
وهذه الاشتباكات خفيفه والمتباعده التي
نستمع اليها بين فتره واخرى نذهب الى
منطقه اخرى من العاصمه السودانيه منطقه ام
درمان معك مقداد ما الذي دار في الساعات
الماضيه عندك في اندرمان
مرحبا صهيب وبالمشاهدين نعم كما اشار عمار
الى ان الحاله الان فيها حاله كبيره جدا
من السكون والهدوء في مختلف جبهات القتال
لكن مدينه ام درمان عاده ما تستيقظ على
اصوات من المدفعيه الثقيله التي تدوي
بصوره عنيفه للغايه وتستهدف تمركزات قوات
الدعم السريع هذا اليوم بدا بدوي قصف
مدفعي قوي للغايه استيقظنا اثره صباحا
استهدفت مركزات لقوات الدعم السريع في
مناطق متفرقه على الاغلب انها في مدينه
بحري شمال مدينه بحري حيث جسر الحلفايه
والذي دارت فيه عده اشتباكات هذا اليوم
اشتباكات كانت عنيفه للغايه استخدم فيها
الطيران الجوي ايضا غارات جويه مكثفه ايضا
استهدفت هذه
المعسكرات في جنوب مدينه ام درمان حيث
منطقه الصالحه وهي في اقصى جنوب مدينه ام
درمان كل هذه المناطق تشهد اشتباكات كانت
في الساعات الاولى من الصباح في منطقه
المهندسين والفتحاب بحسب ما افادت مصادر
ميدانيه انها انها كانت ايضا تشهد
اشتباكات في هذا الصباح وسمع ذوي لطلقات
ناريه في مناطق متفرقه في ام درمان
القديمه في هذا اليوم ايضا حلق الطيران
الحربي بصوره كثيفه نهار هذا اليوم استمر
القصف المدفعي وهدا في الساعات المتاخره
والاولى من الليل ولكن كان هذا اليوم
ساخنا وعنيفا بعد هذه الهدنه هدنه ال24
ساعه التي صمدت بصوره واضحه واحتمت بصوره
كبيره للغايه اليوم بدا عنيفا على عده
جبهات قتال في الخرطوم ايضا في المنطقه
الصناعيه وشارع الغابه وبالقرب من سلاح
المدرعات ومنطقه شرق النيل كل هذه المناطق
تجددت فيها جبهات القتال بصوره واسعه
وصوره شرسه للغايه فقد فيها المواطنون
السكون الذي يعني
لمسوه في يوم الهدنه التي دامت في 24 ساعه
وصمدت بصوره كبيره واحترمت بصوره كبيره
الزميلان المقداد حسن وعمار ابو شيبه من
ام درمان والخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لكما
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه سلطات فيلادلفيا
الامريكيه تؤكد انهيار طريق سريع رئيسي في
الولايه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اخبار الساعه
مشاهدينا يريدوني الان في هذه اللحظات ان
هناك بيانا سعوديا امريكيا مشتركا بشانه
الهدنه في السودان الهدنه الاخيره التي
استمرت اليوم الواحد اذا الولايه الولايات
المتحده والسعوديه تنديدان بتجدد العنف في
السودان فور انتهاء هذه الهدنه اليوم
الواحد
وطبعا عوده الاشتباكات كما تبعنا قبل قليل
قبل الفاصل في السودان عقب انتهاء هذه
الهدنه التي دامت يوما واحدا رغم انها
ثبتت اكثر وجرا الالتزام بها اكثر من
الهدن السابقه من قبل الطرفين من قبل
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع اذا
مشاهدينا هذا ولدنا للتو بيان سعودي
امريكي حول عوده الاشتباكات في السودان
بعد انتهاء الهدنه
نذهب الى ملفنا التالي في اخبار الساعه
طيف اعاده احياء الاتفاق النووي الايراني
يقلق تل ابيب التي تسابق الزمن لعرقله
ابرامه فالاخبار الرائجه داخل اسرائيل
تشير الى وجود توافق بين واشنطن وطهران قد
يدفع في اتجاه التوصل الى اتفاق النووي
هذا ما اكدته صحيفه يدعو تحرا النوت
الاسرائيليه والتي كشفت عن تزايد احتمال
التوصل الى اتفاق بين الولايات المتحده
وايران بشان برنامج طهران النووي اوضحت
الصحيفه نقلا عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين ان
عدم دعوه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الى
الولايات المتحده يرجع بالاساس الى عدم
رغبه واشنطن في ان يعرقل ذلك مساعيها في
التوصل لاتفاق مع ايران وترغب طهران في
العوده الى اتفاق 2015 وهو ما تعارضه
واشنطن التي عقدت اتفاقا مؤقتا يشمل صفقه
لتبادل الاسرى والافراج عن الاصول
الايرانيه المجمده
تل ابيب لا تزالوا تاملوا في اجهاض اي
اتفاق محتمل بين الولايات المتحده وايران
وبحثا عن تنميه واشنطن عن مواصله
محادثاتها مع طهران سيجتمع وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي مع وزير الدفاع
في بلد اوروبي لم يتم تحديده حتى الان كما
ان تل ابيب بعثت برساله صارمه الى واشنطن
تحذر فيها من امكانيه استغلال طهران
للاتفاق النووي كغطاء لمواصله مساعيها في
الحصول على الاسلحه النوويه هذا وصرح
نتنياهو بان اي تسويه مع ايران لن تكون
ملزمه لاسرائيل مضيفا ان تل ابيب ستعمل ما
يلزم لحمايه نفسها سواء كان هناك اتفاق مع
ايران ام لا
يوم الخميس الماضي تحدثت مع وزير الخارجيه
الاميركي
واكدت على موقفنا الثابت العوده الى
الاتفاق النووي مع ايران لن توقف برنامج
طيران النووي بل ستسمح لايران فقط بتوجيه
الاموال بمبالغ كبيره الى اذرعها في
المنطقه وحول حدود اسرائيل شددت على ان اي
اتفاق مع ايران لن يلزم اسرائيل مع او
بدون اتفاق سنواصل القيام بكل ما هو ضروري
لحمايه اراضينا
طهران من جهتها مشاهدينا لم تنفي وجود
توافق مع الغرب الى انها رفضت فرض اي
املاءات او قيود عليها بخصوص امكانيه
صنعها لاسلحه النوويه هذا ما جاء على لسان
المرشد الايراني علي خامنئي الذي قال انه
ليس بمقدور اي كان منع ايران من صنع اسلحه
نوويه اذا ارادت ذلك هذا واوضح في الوقت
نفسه ان ايران لا تريد صنع اسلحه نوويه
بسبب عقيدتها الدينيه على حد قوله وليس
لسبب اخر كما اقر بانه من الممكن فعلا ان
تتوصل ايران الى اتفاق مع الغرب شريطه عدم
المساس بالبنيه التحتيه النوويه لايران
يجب عدم المساس بالبنيه التحتيه للصناعه
النوويه خلال هذه السنوات قام المديرون
والمسؤولون والناشطون في هذه الصناعه
باعمال مهمه وانشاوا بنيه تحتيه كبيره قد
ترغبون في عقد اتفاقيات في بعض المجالات
النوويه لا توجد مشكله اتفقوا لكن لا
ينبغي المساس بالبنت تحتيه ولا ينبغي ان
تتضرر يجب احترامها فهذه هي نتائج جهود
الاخرين
اسرائيل تخشى كثيرا مما تصفه بالتهديد
الايراني وهذا ما يدفعها لبذل قصار جهودها
للتحضير لكل السيناريوهات الممكنه بهذا
الخصوص كشفت صحيفه يدعوت احرنوت دائما عن
بدء الجيش الاسرائيلي بالاستعداد مؤخرا
لاحتمال احتمال حقيقي لنشوب حرب مع ايران
وتعمل شعبه الاستخبارات في الجيش
الاسرائيلي على استكمال تحضيراتها للحرب
الاسرائيليه الايرانيه الاولى على حد قول
يدعو تحر العط
خرجا كبيرا في استراتيجيه اسرائيل لمواجهه
ما تصفه بالتهديد الايراني
الاسرائيلي انشا الفرع 54 وهو وحده مخصصه
لمواجهه ايران وتم انشاؤها في قسم الابحاث
في شعبه الاستخبارات الفرع 54 يركز على
دراسه الحرس الثوري استخباراتيا فضلا عن
حزب الله وحركه حماس ايضا ويضم الفرع
الجديد 30 جنديا جلهم من كبار الضباط
الاسرائيليين يشتغلون بتنسيق مع خبراء
امريكيين
خطه اسرائيل الجديده تاتيك نتيجه للقلق
الاسرائيلي المتزايد من التحركات
الايرانيه الاخيره فئران عززت قواتها
العسكريه بشكل واضح كما ان العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه مع روسيا والصين
عرفت تطورا واضحا يضاف الى ذلك امكانيه
ابرام اتفاق النوويه مع ايران ما يعني
تخفيف العقوبات المفروضه عليها وبالتالي
منحها قوه اضافيه
معنى من القدس المحلل السياسي
اهلا بك معنا ما اكثر ما تخشاه اسرائيل من
عوده امريكا الى الاتفاق النووي مع ايران
لا تخشى من الاتفاق الذي تسعى اليه
الولايات المتحده هو شطب الموضوع النووي
الايراني من جدول الاعمال والاهتمام
الامريكي اي الانتهاء من ما يكن من نتائج
وشطف هذا الموضوع كليا هذا بالاضافه الى
ان الاتفاق حسب ما
ورد حتى الان من معلومات لا يفرضوا اي
رقابه على المنشات النوويه الايرانيه لا
يفرض عليها اي عقوبات لا يهدد ايران في
حال خلقها للاتفاق الاموال التي سيتم
تحويل الى ايران بسبب رفع العقوبات
الاقتصاديه المفروض عليها والتي تقدر
بمئات المليارات من الدولارات سترصد ليس
لشؤون الداخليه الاملائيه في ايران بل
سترصد الى تعزيز القوى الايرانيه
ايضا الى التمدد ومشاريع الارهاب الايراني
في شتى انحاء العالم
كل هذا هو بمثابه تخشى منه اسرائيل ولذلك
تحاول بكل قوه التاثير على واشنطن للعدول
عن هذا الاتفاق ام او الضم بعض الشروط
التي يجب على ايران اليها مع التوجيه
التهديدا
في حيفا يمكن لاسرائيل ان تقنع الولايات
المتحده باعطائها هذه الضمانات او اعطائها
هذه التطمينات في حال ابرام الاتفاق
النووي مره اخرى والعلاقه متوتره بين
نتنياهو وبايدن
لضعفه مكانتها في التشويش او عرقله او
التاثير على
واشنطن خاصه في هذا في دول المتوسطه او
السلبيه القائمه بين اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده ولذلك اللقاء المرتبط بين وزيرين
الدفاع الاسرائيلي والامريكي هو بمثابه
محاوله اخيره لاقناع واشنطن بذلك
قدم الوثائق وهو بانه في حال تم الاتصال
رسائل اسرائيل ستكون حره
بالتصرف سواء بالاتفاق او بدونه سواء
بموافقه امريكيه او بدونها لان اسرائيل
بفكتوريا القيام
بضرب المنشات النوويه الايرانيه بمفردها
وذلك انطلاقا من مبدا الحفاظ على ضمان
امنها وضمان سلامه سكانها
التهديد
في حال ما اذا شنت اسرائيل هكذا ضربات كما
تفضلت على المنشات النوويه الايرانيه ما
ستكون العواقب يعني ان تتحدث عن امكانيه
شن هذه الحرب او هذه الضربات العسكريه
بدون الضوء الاخضر الامريكي او الموافقه
الامريكيه في هذه الحاله كيف ستكون
انعكاسات على اسرائيل
لا شك انها ستكون تداعيات واسعه
على اسرائيل بل ايضا على الجميع
لا تاخذه هذا بالحسبان ولذلك تحذر من مغبه
هذا الاحتمال وعلى الولايات المتحده اخذ
هذا الموضوع بالحسبان لان التداعيات ليس
فقط على اسرائيل بل ايضا على امنه وسلامه
من تركه الشرق الاوسط وعلى السلام الدولي
وجهه النظر الاسرائيليه تقول بان الحرب
الاولى بين الجيشين الاسرائيلي والايراني
ستنتقل اولا الى داخل الاراضي الايرانيه
لهناك بنك للاهداف التي
اتسعها وتبنيها تبنيه اسرائيل
على القرار الايراني الداخلي وهذه وهذه
الاهداف هي ضعف في ايران خاصه في ضوء
مساحتها الواسع والشاسعه ولذلك ايضا هناك
لا شك ان هذا سيؤخذ بالحسبان اما بالنسبه
لعوامل هذه الحرب فهي ستكون حسب الاعتقاد
حرب استنزاف
عصريه الاولى من نوعها في العالم
تتطلب طول النفس من قبل اسرائيل وايضا
المثابره من قبل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
الداخلي كل هذا يندرج في اطار
حساب الاسرائيلي الداخلي والخارجي الذي
سيطرح العملات المتحده والذي اخذ بالعجمان
لدى مجمل الموضوع المناوره العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي انتهت قبل يومين اخذت
هذه المواضيع بالحسبان حيث من من حيث
الوصول الى ايران مثلا
السلاح الجو الاس
برحلات طويله
طويله المدى على مده عده ساعات متواصله
وبهذا اثبت جدارته من جهه وايضا
التجارب او المناوره اخر لم تاخذ الحسبان
تدخل امريكي او تدخل القوات الاجنبيه اخرى
الى جانب اسرائيل اي الاعتماد على اسرائيل
بقوتها الذاتيه فقط لا غير شكرا جزيلا لك
السياسي كنت معنا من القدس
[موسيقى]
افاد رئيسه هيئه الدفاع عن الرئيس العراقي
الاسبق صدام حسين الدكتور خليل الدليمي
خلال احدى حلقات برنامج الذاكره السياسيه
الذي يقدمه الزميل طاهر بركه بان الحبل
الذي نفذ به اعدام صدام حسين كان مكونا من
39 عقده وهو عدد الصواريخ التي اطلقتها
بغداد ضد تل ابيب ابان حرب الخليج هل صحيح
انه عدد عقد الحبل حبل المشنقه كان على
عدد صواريخ التي ضربها صدام حسين على
اسرائيل
قاعه المحكمه قاعه الاعدام
على عدد الصواريخ التي قصف بها اسرائيل
هل مات شنقا فعلا
كانت عمليه اعدام عمليه غوائيه
يعني انت تؤكد لنا الشكوك حول
موته شنقا نعم عمليه غوائيه عمليه اعدامه
من اطلاق الشعارات الى التهديد الى اخر
مرحله
هو الذي رفض فعلا وضع الكيس نعم
عندما تقول غوغائيه يعني تتجاوز الشنق
هكذا تفسر
ماذا كان دور الضباط الايرانيين
ايثار رساله انه احنا اللي عدمناك فقط
في معلومات تقول انه كان عندهم اهداف اخرى
متعلقه بالتاكد من هويه من يقومون باعدامه
ربما
يعني اخذوا مثلا
اشياء معينه من جسده للدي ان اي للفحوص
لا اعتقد
ماذا حصل بالجثمان بعد الوفاه
نقل الى بيت نور المالكي تشفيا
في يوم زواج
نجله احمد
من اربيل معنا عضو لحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني محمد زنجنه استاذ محمد اهلا بك
معنا ما رايك فيما قاله السيد الدليمي في
هذا التصريح بان حبل المشنقه الذي لف حول
الرئيس العراقي الاسبق صدام حسين كان فيه
39 عقده
اشاره الى
الصواريخ التي تم اطلاقها على اسرائيل
نعم مساء الخير تحيه طيبه لكم وللزملاء
والمشاهدين اعتقد بان السيد خليل يبالغ
كثيرا في التصريحات التي يطلقها وخصوصا
انه واحد من الثلاثه الذين دائما يصورون
افلام خياليه عن صدام حسين وعائله صدام
حسين هو الرجل كل في كل الاحوال هو متوفي
وانتم تعلمون راي اقليم كردستان وراي
الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني حول مساله
الاعدام وطريقه الاعدام وتكررت لاكثر من
مره من الرئيس مسعود بارزاني وصولا الى
اصغر شخص في الاقليم ولكن يعني الثلاثه هم
رغد صدام حسين وشبيه عدي او بديل الشيطان
كما يسمي نفسه لطيف يحيى وخليل الدليمي
بكل صراحه لا اعتقد ان هناك مبرر للاطراف
العراقيه من وجود هذه العقد 39 هذا اولا
ثانيا هناك طرفه فيما يتعلق بالصواريخ
التي اطلقت على اسرائيل وسمعتها من الشيخ
احمد ياسين رحمه الله قال بان هذه
الصواريخ التي اطلقت على اسرائيل قتلت
مواطنا اسرائيليا واحدا وبسبب الصدمه اي
انه حتى هذه الصوا في وقتها لم يكن لها
هذا التاثير الذي من الممكن ان يهز
اسرائيل اذا بكل صراحه اعتقد بان السيد
الدليمي ومن خلال ما يطرحه به هذا في هذه
الاراء يحاول ان يجذب لنفسه الانظار
ويحاول محاولات سياسيه عابره على القانون
ان يبين لنفسي بانه كان نجما وهو يتحدث عن
حقوق يعني ربما الحديث عن العقد هو محاوله
للحديث عن جانب التشفي في الرئيس العراقي
الاسبق صدام حسين لانه سمعت كذلك من
السيده رغد صدام حسين
ابنه صدام حسين انه كان هناك عناصر
ايرانيه حاضره يوم اعدام صدام حسين بمعنى
انه كان هناك
نوع من الثار من قبل بسبب الحرب الايرانيه
مثلا هنا وكان هناك ايضا فيديو متداول على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي عن نقل جثمان
صدام حسين كذلك للنظر اليه من قبل خصومه
كذلك الا يمكن ان يكون هذا الكلام يعني
نابعا من مساله الثار من صدام حسين
حتى في وقتها قالوا بان من لف الحبل على
رقبه صدام حسين كان سمحت السيد مقتدى
الصدر هذا الكلام يعني تم تداوله منذ
اعدام صدام حسين وحتى هذه اللحظه ويتكرر
شيئا فشيئا التشفي موجود نعم اعدام صدام
حسين في اول يوم عيد الاضحى المبارك هذا
امر صراحه غير مقبول لا انسانيا ولا
قانونيا بغض النظر عن كل الجرائم التي
ارتكبها بحق الشعب العراقي هذه كانت كانت
غلطه كبيره ارتكبتها الحكومه العراقيه لكن
المالكي كسب بها نقطه جدد من خلالها
الولايه الثانيه من خلال الانتخابات التي
حصلت في تلك المره وفي نفس اليوم تم قتل
ثلاثين شيعي من قبل اطراف تابعه لحزب
البعث او منشقه عن حزب البعث او متوحده من
القاعده وغير القاعده قتلوا 30 شخصا لانه
قتل في يوم
30/12/206 من ضمنهم احد اقوال زوجتي والتي
كانت تسكن في بغداد في تلك الفتره اذا بكل
صراحه نعم من الممكن ان يكون هناك
ايرانيين متخفيين في امن عراقيين او افراد
امن عراقي ولكن الصرخات التي اطلقت كانت
صرخات عراقيه كانت صرخات من شيعه العراق
دائما تطلق يعني عجل فرجه والعن عدوه ولكن
مساله تكرار اسم مقتدى ثلاثه مرات هل كان
السيد مقتدى الصدر املي علي المقتدى
هناك ايضا جانب يعني ليست كل المعلومات
كما تصفها صحيحه ولكن بالفعل هناك جانب
ثار من صدام حسين تجسد في العديد من
الملاحظات او المناسبات كذلك طيب سيد
زنكنا اذا كان سيد الدليمي تعتقد انه
مساله العقد الموجوده في حبل المشنقه ليست
حقيقيه ما الغرض من هذه التصريحات الان ما
الهدف الحقيقي برايك من خلال هذا الكلام
عندما نسمعه من السيد الدليمي الان عبر
شاشه العربيه
يعني هي مساله بحث عن نجوميه وشهره ليست
اكثر بكل صراحه هي نفس المساله التي من
خلالها الف بديل عدي صدام حسين كتاب بديل
الشيطان والذي انتج من خلاله فيلم سينمائي
كان مغايرا عن الحقيقه تماما خليل الدليمي
يريد ان يسلك نفس السلوك يريد ان يبني
لنفسه مستقبلا سياسيا في العراق عسى ولعل
ان يحدى يحدث اي تغيير في العمليه
السياسيه العراقيه ويعود من جديد نحن نعلم
بان كانت هناك الشخصيات كثيره مصريه
اردنيه قطريه كانت تدافع عن صدام حسين
وهناك نقطه مهمه ايضا يعني عدا التسعه
وثلاثين عقده مساله انه عرض عليه ان يسافر
الى عمان او الى مصر الوحيد الذي عرض على
صدام حسين ان يخرج بكرامته من العراق كان
سمو الشيخ زايد رحمه الله وهذا الطلب رفض
من قبل صدام حسين اذا مساله هذه العقد
يعني تشبيهها بعمر صدام حسين وما شابه حتى
يقال بانه مواليد 37 وليست 37 هذا ما مسجل
في السجلات المدنيه اذا لماذا
هذا بالاضافه الى ذلك هو يريد ان يعني
يلعب بعواطف الشعب العراقي وخصوصا من
مازال يتحسر على ايام صدام حسين بعدما
شهدناه من اوضاع كانت اسوا بكثير لاننا في
ديمقرا في ديكتاتوريه في قالب الديمقراطيه
على الاقل في ذلك الوقت كانت الديكتاتوريه
الصريحه واليوم تعاني مدن العراق معاناه
كثيره وكبيره لم تعانيها حتى في فترات
صدام حسين اذا هذه المساله استغلال وفتح
الطريق من اجل مستقبل سياسي في داخل
العراق وخصوصا ان هناك تسجيل جديد لحزب
البعث في الاردن وهناك محاولات لاعاده
احياء حزب البعث ان كان في العراق وهناك
الشماعه او خرااعه خضره نحن نسميها
باللهجه العراقيه دائما يعني تحملها
امريكا وتلوح بها للاطراف الشيعيه كي
تستجيب لها باعاده الحياه الى حزب البعث
من جديد اعتقد بان السيد الدليمي يريد
اقتناص الفرص ليس اكثر شكرا جزيلا لك على
تعليقك سيد محمد زنك نه عضو الحزمه
الديمقراطي الكردستاني كنت معنا من اربيل
[موسيقى]
الى الولايات المتحده حيث اكدت سلطاته
فيلادلفيا الامريكيه سقوطه جزء من جسر على
احد اكثر الطرق استخداما شرقا البلاد لذلك
بعد اندلاع حريق واشارت سلطاته الى عدم
وقوع ضحايا جراء الحادث
[موسيقى]
نبقى في الولايات المتحده لمتابعه
القضائيه تواصل ملاحقه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دوت ترامب هذه المره يتابع ترامب
يتابع بتهمه جنائيه في قضيه احتفاضه
بملفات سريه في منزله بعد نهايه ولايته
كرئيس الرئيس الجمهوري السابق اختار ولايه
جورجيا للظهور في اول خطاب له بعد توجيهه
لائحه الاتهامات او توجيه لائحه الاتهامات
اليه كان كعادته ساخيا في توجيه سهام
الانتقاد للجهات القضائيه دون ان يفوت
فرصه مهاجمه الرئيس الحالي
انتم تشاهدون كيف يحاول جو بايدن سجن
منافسه السياسي الرئيسي فكر قليلا بذلك
هذا تماما ما يفعله قاده دول العالم
الثالث الذين يفضلون سجن خصومهم بدلا من
مواجهتهم انتخابيا الامر واضح وبسيط
مرتبطا بالمتابعه القضائيه تماما كارتباطه
بالترشح لمنصب الرئيس المتابعات القضائيه
المختلفه التي تلاحق الرجل اثار التساؤلات
حقيقيه حول مدى قدرته على اكمال مشوار
التنافس على كرسي الرئاسه على الصعيد
القانوني لا يزال ترشح ترامب جائزا
فالدستور الامريكي لا يمنع ترشح اي شخص
مدان او لديه سجل اجرامي من الترشح
للرئاسه طالما انه مستوفر للشروط الثلاثه
وهي ان يكون من مواليد الولايات المتحده
وان لا يقل عمره عن 35 عاما وان يقوم او
ان اقام في الولايات المتحده لمده 14 عاما
متواصله على الاقل
سياسيا قد يكون من الصعب على المرشح
المتهم الذي قد يصبح مدانا ان يفوز باصوات
الناخبين لكن وضع ترامب يختلف نسبيا حيث
انه يحظى بقاعده جماهيريه واسعه كما انه
كسب تعاطف فئات من الجماهير من خلال تصوير
نفسه كضحيه لمؤامرات سياسيه المفارقه لان
انتخاب اي مرشح كرئيس لا يلغي التهم
المرفوعه ضدها علما ان الدستور يعطيه
كرئيس حق منح العفو الرئاسي لمتهمين اخرين
ورغم ان الدستور يسمح للرئيس بممارسه
مهامه من زنزانته الا ان الامر لم يحدث من
قبل ما قد يدخل البلاد في ازمه دستوريه
يعرف التهم الموجهه اليه في قضيه الملفات
السريه ممثلون لدعاء كشفوا على لائحه
اتهام بحق ترامب شملت 37 تهمه منها تعريض
بعض الاسرار الامنيه الاكثر حساسيه في
البلاد للخطر معلومات مرتبطه بملفات عديده
كالاسلحه النوويه الامريكيه واقمار التجسس
الصناعي
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه في
باكستان ارتفاع حصيله ضحايا امطار شمال
غرب البلاد لخمسه وعشرين قتيلا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كتبت الحياه من جديد
لاربعه اطفال بينهم رضيع بعد ان قضوا
اربعين يوما من الضياع في غابات الامازون
والد الاطفال الناجيين منويل عبر عن مدى
سعادته بانقاذ اطفاله من موت محقق بعد
ضياع استمر لاربعين يوما موضحا انه لم
يستطع التحدث معهم حتى الان بسبب وضعهم
الصحي التثمي اول ما فعلته هو الحديث الى
طفله البالغه من العمر 13 عاما ليس من
السهل سؤالهم لان الاطفال لم ياكلوا جيدا
لمده اربعين يوما لذلك لم اتمكن من الحصول
على اي معلومات منهم نامل ان يتعافى
الاطفال بشكل جيد انها معجزه من الله
وهنا سجلت احداث مثيره بل اكثر اطفال في
دهاليز الامازون لم يعرف لهم اثر لاربعين
يوما
حوى الطائرتهم الى هنا بهذا الشكل توفي
الجميع ليبدا سيناريو لحكايه نجاه لثلاثه
اطفال ورضيع
لا تتجاوز اعمارهم الثلاثه عشر عاما كيف
عاشت اجسادهم في غابات هي الاخطر اجابت
ليسلي الاخت الكبرى بعد انقاذهم معجزه
البقاء تعود لدقيق الكسافه ومهارات تمييز
بين النباتات اتقنتها الطفله من جدتها
عمليه التفتيش تعقدت خيوطها في كولومبو
لاسابيع تفككت بفضل ليسلي ابنه الثلاثه
عشر عاما تركت اثارا في اماكن مختلفه
لترشد المنقذين اليها
المجتمع المحلي والقوات العسكريه كانوا
يبحثون معا ووجدنا الاطفال بعد اربعين
يوما لكن هم وحدهم من سهل لنا الطريق
وتمكنوا من ان يكونوا قدوه للبقاء حادثه
ستسجل في التاريخ
وصلوا محملين بتاريخ من الصمود كما عبر
المجتمع الكولومبي وايضا بحكايه نجاح
سيتسابق عليها منتج الافلام لسرد قصه
باحداث اكثر واقعيه واثاره قصه لابد ان
تنتهي بتصفيق جماهري حار كما الواقع ايضا
غذاء سالم العربيه
[موسيقى]
تواصل قوافل الحجاج توافدها الى مكه
المكرمه والمدينه المنوره في طريقها الى
المشاعر المقدسه استعدادا لاداء مناسك
الحج هذا العام ووسط توقعاتهم بتدفق
ملايين الحجاج الى المشاعر المقدسه خلال
الايام المقبله عملت الجهات المختصه على
تجهيز 160 الف مخيم لاستقبال الحجاج في
مشعري وعرفات حيث تم تزويد هذه المخيمات
بكافه الخدمات التي يتطلبها الحاج
[موسيقى]
تزايدت في السنوات الاخيره حالات العثور
على رفات جنود فقدوا خلال الحرب العالميه
الاولى وذلك بعد مرور ما يزيد عن قرن من
انتهاء الحرب نتابع
[موسيقى]
قالت السلطات الباكستانيه ان امطارا غزيره
اجتاحت شمال غرب باكستان مما ادى الى
انهيار عده منازل 25 شخصا واصابه 145
اخرين
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز
العناوين
في اوكرانيا روسيا تصده هجومين تستعيد
ثلاثه بلدات
بعد اوامر من شيغو بريجوجن قائدو فاجنر
يتحدى من جديد ويرفض توقيع عقود مع وزاره
الدفاع
تفاهمات واشنطن وطهران بشان الاتفاق
النووي تدفع اسرائيل للاستعداد عبر
استحداث فرع جديد للتعامل مع ايران
في قصه شغلت العالم والد احد الاطفال
النجينه من غابات الامازون يروي تفاصيل
الاتصال الاول
شكرا على المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات